[Music]
you know never to turn your back on me
i'm not in the mood
mood
mood's a thing for cattle and love play
what did you just say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a huge thanks to razer and nvidia studio
for sponsoring this video and be sure to
stick around if you guys want to know
more about the world's fastest laptops
built for creators
[Music]
so the new dune movie has tons of
incredible visual effects works from a
huge team of amazingly talented artists
but they missed out on the most critical
thing from the story they didn't have
the freaking vomiting alien warm pigs
something that i was kind of
disappointed and that they didn't have
the words the shields in the new dune
movie were so non-blocky it left me with
so much disappointment that i just like
i couldn't help but find my mind
wandering and wondering what would these
people look like with proper shields
it's like what happens if you took that
action scene that was well choreographed
and you covered it with blocks so you
couldn't see what's going on with the
popularity of minecraft these days how
do you not take advantage of that you
know how do you go away from the blocks
when the blocks are a hot commodity okay
everyone's blocking right now blockchain
get on the block train y'all so these
shields are an example of something from
the book that are done in two very
different ways so let's start by looking
at the shields from the new dune movie
so i will say that i know we're doing a
bit about the shields and all but like
the new shields are pretty sweet yeah so
they're very tastefully done yes it's
very clear what's a hit with the red
color and the blue color indicating when
the shield is working we've talked about
how this effect is done on visual
effects artists react before it it's
literally just rotoscope your character
you tint it completely blue or
completely red and you offset it maybe
add a little bit of a scale wiggle to it
any time their hits make it through the
shield you get that red hit very classic
it's visually communicating what's going
on very effectively now let's take a
look at the original doom movie shields
the masterpiece let's take a look at
some effects that took literally a year
to make
and there's woo
oh man look at how good those shields
look oh man
this is so good
jump this i get like i get that they're
safe behind these shields i understand
that and it's just you can just tell how
time-consuming that was to do back then
in the 80s uh there were no 3d programs
they wanted to emulate the sort of 3d
look that you would get in say a movie
like tron but they didn't have the the
knowledge or the ability to actually
deliver that sort of 3d effect so they
did it all by hand manually with
rotoscoping out squares and rectangles
so this was it all an optical process
that happened for real through like a
film gate and exposing it on camera
after they cut out their little pieces
of film that means every single stroke
every single outline was made from
scratch
for every single frame
anytime you see the black line that's
not like an intentional black line that
they put in there that is an artifact
from the rotoscoping that they did
because when you rotoscope something
it's literally the process of cutting
out like one rectangle from the film
exposing it with something else to
achieve this sort of optical thing but
when they put it back up you have to
align it perfectly because when you
don't align it perfectly you end up with
what you're seeing there that black line
and you can also see that on each of the
surfaces of the cube it's refracting the
light behind it differently it's like an
offset it looks like a little offset on
every single plane it's not like an
actual refraction either
it's it's just like oh this layer behind
this face is going to be shifted this
way yeah this layer we're just going to
scale up a little bit
[Music]
david lynch is a genius
he has never done anything wrong and in
fact he was robbed of his artistic
vision when they made this new hot
garbage of a movie so to fulfill david
lynch's original genius vision we are
going to take his idea of adding these
cool shields to the new dune movie to
preserve his legacy forever that's
motivating for you lynching yeah throw
two up in the air is he dead no he's
alive oh i was like i was scared for a
second throughout this process we'll be
using the awesome razer blade 17 laptops
which are powered by nvidia geforce rtx
3080 tis this is the first ti gpu to
come in a laptop form factor i'm
predicting some long hours spent on
these effects so these laptops will
prevent us from getting stranded at our
desks the whole week while still
maintaining the same performance we've
come to expect from our desktop pcs
that's because nvidia geforce rtx 30
series laptop gpus power the world's
fastest laptops plenty fast touring
about these cube shields so honestly
this is just an excuse to explore how
these effects were made back in the day
using new techniques you were saying you
wanted to do this manually mm-hmm yeah
so you're you're a maniac so listen guys
i know y'all are going to use your fancy
you know vfx 3d programs but i want to
try it the way it was actually done
you're going to do it on film
okay maybe not entirely how it was
actually
but i want to painstakingly frame by
frame go in and try to match the look of
this completely in 2d so how are we
going to do it then i think i mean shoot
i'm going 3d i'm not let's use let's use
what the good lord gave us i say all
right guys put your hands in
okay slower
we got like a little uh i don't even
know dude it's like a little minecraft
wannabe
dude
they literally face through each other
oh damn so you know we've got about 15
shots to do within this week and it's
already tuesday so gotta try and find
the quickest possible work around to get
these things done i'm
avoiding any and all camera animation
any and all camera tracking i'm going
purely eyeball kind of hand animating a
skeleton over the important keyframes to
get something like this that said it is
weird spending this much time making a
fight scene objectively worse
that's something i'm still coming to
terms with for any parts of their body
that break out of kind of the larger
boxy body shield you see oh man this is
crazy
[Laughter]
and then any time they over i see i keep
seeing you
hey you just i mean hey you just wish
you looked like this
because i do too
this is a very weird experience wearing
this and if you want to find out more
subscribe to quarterdigital.com son of a
dungeon season two what's happening i
created just some simple box geometry
around each of these skeletons and
parented it to the appropriate part of
the body i used like some light
weighting system to just bend the boxes
in an appropriate way to get something
like this
right now i've got this all modeled and
animated the issue is we've still got a
lot of individual boxes clipping through
each other and we don't want that so i'm
going to convert all of these boxes that
pertain to each of these characters into
what is called an sdf which is a signed
distance field which only worries about
the surface all of the geometry inside
will be removed which solves our problem
because again if we make this refractive
and we make this transparent you're
going to see the corners of all the
boxes inside the boxes and we don't want
any of that we only want to worry about
what's peaking through the surface so
i'm going to convert these into a volume
and then i'm going to mesh that volume
meaning i'm going to convert that volume
back into geometry and what that will do
that's really cool is it will soften the
edges it'll curve them and again remove
or cull any of the geometry inside the
boxes which is exactly the aesthetic
we're going for now that i've done this
portion i need to move on to the actual
texturing and lighting and rendering of
this just to make sure that it's working
as intended so let's see how that looks
this is my first time watching this
right now and
[Music]
i like it do you okay great great it
actually looks like glass
there still needs to be some compositing
done on this to like bring it home
because it still feels a little too
crisp and like high resolution you know
i'm really i'm really digging this
effect this is looking good because it's
totally got that original movie
aesthetic going on but it has like a
modern sheen across it yeah well you
know a few boys i mean this is great and
all and it looks all modern and
futuristic and all that but if you want
the old-school way with all the jank
included i got something for you right
okay i got to see this so you spent the
entire day yesterday working on how many
shots five six
i spent the entirety of yesterday
working on one shot
but i got it done i got the shot done
i got the shot done but you know what
before i say anything more i want to see
the shot okay let's take a look
this is the shot dude i mean
aesthetically you're on point dude i
love i do love your work with the hang
coming out with this little knife thank
you it had to twirl like the twirling
was like
ruining my life a lot of yesterday was
figuring out how the aesthetics gonna
look um as soon as i added the sheen i
was like oh this is
this is the dune effect so great this
means that now you can just copy and
paste this on to the next shot right
yeah exactly no not at all why you can't
here let me show you
let me show you what as you can see
every shot is at a slightly different
angle and the the geometry like looks
different it's from a different
perspective so i have to create the
shape uh from scratch
it's a it truly is like a mind
bending
animation to think about 2d shapes in 3d
and try to like simulate a 3d look
it's hard enough to do in after effects
i can't imagine how they did it on film
i've always thought that like we as vfx
artists are in the game of like poor
deals where we trade a lot of our time
for just a little result and this feels
like it really captures the spirit of
that where you dedicated like eight
hours to
it's like two seconds maybe like that's
one of the longer ones then i'm guessing
no it's not no it's like a short one i'm
trying so hard to be an optimist for you
man
okay well you know what i think this is
very good progress you've gotten one
shot out of 15 done and you got two more
days oh good lord
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hey matt just want to check in on you
buddy
just checking in how you doing
you doing okay
yo what's up dude
i figured i'd get out of the office for
a little while get some fresh air you
know because why stay in that musty
office no point right if you can work
remote you may as well do it so i'm just
chilling doing my thing in 3d
[Music]
the birds are chirping i got a couple
nostrils full of fresh air and it's all
thanks to this baby right here the razer
blade 17. it's got a built-in nvidia
geforce rtx 3080 ti that's some friggin
desktop computing power right there on
my lap these beautiful razer blade 17s
are razor thin but made of sturdy milled
aluminum the 17 inch display outputs at
144 hertz in 4k and the same is true of
its brother the razer blade 15. this
puppy's equipped with nvidia's geforce
rtx 3080 ti which is exactly what i need
to get my work done quickly in cinema 4d
and after effects the nvidia geforce rtx
30 series laptop gpus power the world's
fastest laptops for gamers and creators
and with rapid core scaling and cpu
optimization i can kick these cube
shield renders out seven times faster
than the latest macbook pro 16. so
having a fast machine is super important
especially with these kinds of renders
because there's a lot of different
passes to send out for these shields to
look the way that i want them to look
the first pass is obviously our main box
geometry right it's the refractive glass
but with that geometry it gets a little
muddy when they're turning when they're
rotating when they're moving all quick
you can't really tell where the edges of
the box are and the reality is they
didn't choreograph this scene thinking
about giant cubes wrapped around the
actors with good reason so as i was
building these boxes around them they
were intersecting a lot and it started
to look a little weird so i thought
maybe we use that to our advantage we
somehow turn that into a hit effect so
what i was thinking was
i've already converted all of this
geometry into a volume well i can go
ahead and i can use those volumes and i
can bool between the two boolean is
taking one piece of geometry and using
it to affect another whether that be
subtracting where they intersect or
making it so that only the intersections
exist which is exactly what i did so we
have paul shield and we have gurney
shield and anywhere where they intersect
it deletes all information it deletes
all geometry except for that collision
which is fantastic because what i did is
i rendered that out and i added it on
top of the comp as a glow so in a way
you actually have a realistic
intersection going on that's composited
back on top of the original render
volumes and bools baby
volumes and pools baby we've got our
refractive glass render we've got our
curvature render we've got our
intersection render now it's time to
throw it all in the pan and stir fry up
some magic i used the geometry from
these exports in order to make mattes
where i could cut out certain sections
of the background plate and i
turbulently displaced it
[Music]
just like in the original where you've
got some warbling of the actors encased
inside of these boxes i then threw on
the curvature as another additive layer
to
add glow and definition to the edges of
the boxes and as a last little cherry on
top i decided to add some electricity
when the hits were taking place kind of
an homage to the original the idea when
i started this was to make it look as
similar to the original as possible
but halfway through i changed my mind so
this is kind of uh in a weird way a
modern take i took some creative
liberties i hope david lynch isn't too
mad at me and if he is
well shoot dude that sucks
i cannot imagine having to do this the
way the original artist had to
completely in 2d
matt are you okay dude
just pee yourself
oh yeah yeah man i'm fine oh jesus
i just had to get away
from that office the desk there's so
many cubes around
you may think that i'm being dramatic
with this but there's a reason why this
is soul crushing and i didn't realize
how hard it was until i actually went to
execute it luckily with this razer blade
17 i can crush my soul from the comfort
of my own bed so let's get into it the
original techniques required them to
draw
every frame onto pieces of film and then
transfer those under onto a master film
well we're not going to be able to do
that that's that's ridiculous that'll
take months and probably kill me if i if
i had to do that so for these purposes
if we're doing it in after effects we're
going to create a network of shape
layers that are rigged and i can animate
each point independently and it all
moves together so that we can animate
across time first step we're going to
create a shape layer around this sword
now we have to think about
the perspective of the objects in
relation to the camera okay so in this
case it's sort of angled away from the
camera slightly so i'm going to create a
new shape right here this is our
foreground plane and then our our side
plane uh so we're basically just
creating our fake 3d geometry but we got
to do something with them because
they're not connected to each other so i
have this plug-in puppet tools 3.0 i
don't think i'd be able to do this
without this and it creates four nulls
that are parented to each of the points
in my shape i can take those nulls and i
can control the shape outside of the
shape layer and we need to parent each
corresponding null together essentially
binding the corners of our shape
together to form a fake 3d cube so once
i have it rigged i have to move
every little piece of geometry here
every little corner for every single
frame once you have a shape done you're
like basically you climb up climb up to
the top of the mountain you're like oh
good i did it and then you see that
there are like 20 other mountains in
this one shot this is just for a
one second shot
we have about 239 layers
i'm just going to say that again we have
239
different layers that are either
controlling shapes or they are shapes
themselves it's actually incredibly hard
to do this and it's kind of i'm kind of
going crazy here i literally
dreamed about this
and then i woke up thinking i was still
at work it gets in your head man these
shapes get in your head they they
literally do it's it's
anyway so once we have our base
animation for all these layers we have a
couple of effects that we're applying
here that basically makes it look
transparent and gives it this sort of
like
heat wave effect believe it or not
there's a plug in a red giant universe
called heat wave so kind of helps us out
a lot we just slap that on make it look
uh pretty close to the original light
hits the surface of 3d geometry
different right so you need to adjust
for that with curves basically i darken
some of the surfaces to give it sort of
this fake uh 3d look one last little
touch here that really really helps sell
this thing i add a little bit of a light
hit creating another shape that
basically just moves across the surface
it basically just creates this look as
if light is being reflected off of the
geometry it's something that they do in
the original a lot and i really wanted
to include that
i think the more that i do it the more
respect i have for what these people did
with no computers they did this entirely
with film transfers just painstaking
labor frame by frame i really respect it
and it also gives me a deep hatred for
david lynch to to ever ever ask this of
his animators
it's so
mind-numbingly difficult
but thanks to these razer blade 17
laptops i was able to get the job done
from the comfort of my own bed so if you
guys are interested in learning more
click the link in the description thanks
again to nvidia studio and razer for
making this video possible
we're here today we're all done all
wrapped up and ready to watch this thing
we had a ton of fun and uh all that's
left is to show it off a little bit
where's matt you know isn't that okay
yeah i haven't seen him in a minute
let's go get him yeah i mean we can go
get him
poor guy
i'm kind of concerned
whoa
dude are you sick too
yeah i don't know how i get sick that's
kind of unrelated but oh buddy
come here come on yeah are you good yeah
i know i'm i'm fine fine i just didn't
want to see the cubes anymore there's a
so many cubes there's so much shapes and
stuff look at that the whole gang's here
hey guys
i'm fine since it's it's good you used
all your sick days though so just
remember that okay
you got it boss
to go home i'm not gonna be paid yeah
it's it's okay so how are you guys
feeling about what you've made did you
guys finish it
um
yeah
yes yeah there's essentially what there
is is matt has prepared a 15 second not
15 seconds is it 15 it's like 15. is it
only 15 seconds both of us oh yeah they
feel so much longer in my mind i was
hoping to do some of these effects but
it's okay
so let's go ahead and take a look at
your thing first
let's do this thing
[Music]
whoa
wow that's saucy
those are saucy
you had time to do a title sequence at
the end oh yeah that's why yours is 25
seconds this looks great jordan honestly
like i'm impressed it's it's cause it's
totally that original dune aesthetic but
with like glossy reflections and
lightning and smoothness to it i don't
know how to describe it other than like
you have realized david lynch's dream
yeah you brought his dream to fruition
i mean i know he did it the first time
but like
you did it again why is there aliasing
in your body yeah i noticed that too yes
so okay so i used volumes right to
create the boxes but because we were a
little low on time i couldn't do enough
of a like a fine voxel resolution to get
a consistent edge i did some smoothing i
just heard a lot of fancy words about
rendering and stuff but like
the original way to do it was like by
hand yeah what is a render
yeah what's a render what is that
all i know is shapes
so here are all of my most painful
moments boiled down to about 15 seconds
here we go
oh my god
yeah
aesthetically
[Laughter]
dude
this looks just like the movie that's
amazing like
jordan's is all swishy and shiny but
yours looks legit you look so legit
you're like garbage shaving like
it's literally just curves adjustments
but it looks so good yeah wait but you
these are like shape layers you're just
yes they're just trying to like make
them look crazy yes
there are 2d shape layers that i am
creating like 3d space for
i'm just creating a dimensionality to
these you're literally creating an
optical illusion based off of like
little rhombuses rumbai the electric too
is great like that's very similar to the
original yeah i tried to match it as
close as possible to the to however i
guess they just scratched the film and
colored it um i'm not sure hand drawn
electricity looked in the 80s oh man
yeah we've lost that one i know right
yeah yeah there's seven shots in here i
believe it's 10 seconds
nine nine seconds so you do did nine
seconds in about seven
days
you are
so insane
why did anyone do this who who would
victor david lynch you are crazy
you know what i'm going to be popping up
dude
[Applause]
man this is like exactly what i was
hoping for when we came up with this
idea i was just like man it would be
nice to see david lynch's shields in the
new dune movie and you guys made it a
reality hey if you guys have any other
examples of some old school visual
effects that could maybe use a sort of
modern reimagining leave a comment down
below we'll take a look at it yeah
especially if they'll prove to be really
hard for matt because that's enjoyable
for all of us here at corridor please
torture me